boredom is one of the most consuming and
disheartening conditions that a human
can be stricken with in the true sense
of the term boredom is the monotonous
and lifeless experience of life itself
to be frequently bored is to be out of
sync and disconnected from life it is
not a natural or useful experience it is
a result of one's over attachment to
daily routine routine is a part of life
we love the comfort and consistency that
routine gives us and we fear the
uncertainty that comes with any
deviation from it
our gravitation towards daily routine is
likely a reflection of our necessity for
internal routine we require consistent
internal functions in order to maintain
physiological health for the purpose of
survival our heartbeat breath blood flow
digestive processes regulatory brain
functions and so on must all adhere to
routine in order to ensure this though
our brain often cast the net of routine
over our entire life when we accept this
paradigm of routine we ignore the fact
that our daily life does not have to
always match our physiological run a
life founded entirely on routine does
not fulfill the more conscious component
of human existence when we live too
heavily with routine we may be alive on
the inside but we are dead on the
outside understanding the different
forms of routine helps one begin to
properly strain them from one another
and apply them appropriately to life
activities that support internal
physiological functions should be kept
in routine keeping on a relative
schedule for things like eating sleeping
meditating exercising and so on allow
your body to fulfill the patterns
necessary for a physically healthy life
activities that support the conscious
enjoyment of life should be removed from
routine things like work habits travels
social engagement recreations and other
things alike these elements of life
should be far less regimented and more
spontaneous the only way to stimulate
the psychological experience of life is
with spontaneity and wonder it is
important that we maintain spontaneity
in life for spontaneity keeps life fresh
while routine dries it out we should
fear the things that temporarily take us
out of boredom but further attach us to
routine things like checking social
media every other minute or watching too
much TV or excessive drinking or heavy
drug use or binge eating or whatever
else one can fill their life up with to
distract themselves from disillusion and
a lack of excitement
these kinds of things distract us from
our boredom but do not eliminate it they
in fact fuel the loop of boredom and
restrict us to temporary solvents we
pile as much tempering relief into our
lives and eventually find ourselves
buried beneath it all covered in boredom
in order to avoid this begin
conditioning yourself out of routines
start small by reducing meaningless
habit forming activities try new things
new people new places and so on push
your comfort zone and let opportunities
carry you in and out of routine without
fear feel the freshness and wonder that
comes from progression and new
experience
feel the life
[Music]